good mornings good afternoon and good
evening everyone depending on the time
zone
this is the talk large-scale data
validation with future by han wong han
is the
tech lead at lyft's machine learning
platform focusing on distributed
computing solutions he is the founder of
the huge project aiming at democratizing
distributed computing and machine
learning please take it away
hello everyone
my name is han
and today i'm going to talk about the
scalable data validation with fugue
and i will
go through a demo first and then just to
wrap up
so let's directly go to the demo for now
so in this demo
assume that we have a very large
collection of color boosts
and we have
data frames recording their colors and
weights
and in this demo we're going to do some
validations on these data frames
either locally or distributedly
let's start
first of all
let's read the data from the disk
and also take a look
at
the sample data
so as you can see this sample data is a
data frame it contains 8 000 rows so
actually there are 8 000 balls it
contains two columns the color
and the weight
and if we draw the histogram
of the weight distribution
by different um by different colors you
will see that
each color they have their own
distribution and it seems they are
normal distributions but we are not sure
so we will find out
through the demo
and also let's take a look at the data
we want to validate on so this has eight
million rows
the original data set
and also here we have
a dictionary called oranges
and this is um the ranges of weight that
someone provided to me
and
they asked me to make sure that for
different colors
the weight must be in these ranges so
this will be another validation task
in this demo
now let's start
the first scenario is we want to
validate for each
value in this data frame
it's within a certain range
and now let me introduce pandera so
pandera is so far one of the most
lightweight python data validation
frameworks
so here we will use pandera to do the
validation
as you can see with pandera we can write
very simple code snippets in order to
enable the validation and then
in order to use pandera you have to
define the dataframe schema in this
dataframe schema we say that we want to
validate weight
and the column
must be in float type and also the value
must be in the range of
between 10 and 500
so this is a very intuitive expression
of a validation logic
and we also have another
data from schema we called better rule
because here we assert that um it's
between 100 and 500 and we know that in
this sample data frame there are some
values that is um
that is
lower than 100 so we expect when we use
this rule to validate this uh the data
frame it should fail so now first of all
let's use the good rule to validate the
sample data and you can see it will just
return original data frame and now let's
use this to validate
and as you can see if we were using
a better rule to validate the sample or
we use a good rule to validate the bad
data we should get the schema error
okay so now let me
introduce fugue so field is
also a lightweight
package python package
it can quickly
turn your
[Music]
native python functions into something
that can
run distributedly on top of a spark task
or any execution engine matrix supports
and in this
in this talk i'm going to use this
transform function from fugue to demo
how you can help on data validation
and we just import this transform from
field
and then we just rewrite this validation
function so instead of say
rule.validatesample just say transform
and here we provide the dataframe and
here we provide the function and also
this parameter means we want the output
to have the same schema as the input
so let's run this
actually this is just a rewrite of
rule.validatesample right so it should
have the same behavior as before and
let's also test this on the other rule
so as expected we will see this schema
error
but the true value of a transform
function is that
now
this data frame no longer needs to be
appended still frame
now it can be a dust data frame it can
be a spark data frame and can be any
data frame that view supports
and also you can specify the execution
engine to tell the system where to run
this validation
so our distributed
computing frameworks
if we
so if we use a distributed computing
framework as our backhand for transform
so this is what will happen
this is the original data frame
and it will be split
to small partitions
based on the default behavior of that
computing framework
and then for each partition we will run
this validate
to validate just this partition and if
everything is fine we will just return
the original data frame
so now let's take a look at an example
how can we um change this sample uh
dependence data frame to something that
is scalable so now let's use task as an
example
so this is the standard way for dusk to
read data from a file system
and now this is a task different
and now to apply this validate on a dash
data frame you just need to change this
data frame to the start stage
and also you can specify the back end to
be dusk so this transform will execute
on the dash cluster
and because we set the backend engine to
be dusk the output will be a native task
data frame so we can call compute to get
the results
so if you want the whole thing to run on
spark you just change this to spark data
frame and set the engine to a spark
session
and you don't have to change this
this validate function and we just make
this function to run distributedly
with different execution engines
okay now let's take a look at another
example so now we want to we have a
hypothesis that
for different color group
the weights are always distributed and
always normally distributed
so in order to do that
first of all let's take a look at the
pandaras um
native expression for this logic and by
the way the pandara this is considered
as a an advanced use case for pandera so
if you cannot follow 100
it is totally fine uh because pandara
has very good documentation and i will
also share this kaggle notebook after
this talk
so look at this function this function
depends on the color value and inside
this function we just return a different
check of pandera called hypothesis so we
want to do hypothesis testing when we
are using normal tests from scipy and as
well as the thresholds but these two are
very tricky
so because we want to validate
the distribution by each color
so we just need to specify the group by
color and to specify the value here in
the samples
with this function what we have to do is
we have to go through
the unique colors from sample and for
each color we need to create
the check
in this sample actually we have eight
colors so this contains eight elements
and we put these checks in this uh
weight
validation and then this is the logic
for the original pandera expression so
the real problem for this
is not only uh it's a little bit
tedious but
think about that if we have eight colors
probably is fine
but if what if we have eight thousand or
eighty thousand colors eighty thousand
partitions
then these checks
will be a huge array
so this idea cannot scale very well on a
distributed system or on very large data
set
and also here with this rule right and
we just validate on the entire data set
it took
15.7 seconds to finish the validation
now let's take a look how few can help
in this case
so in field remember we use transform
function actually in transform function
if you provide a partition
parameter then fugue will take care of
the logical partition for the data set
no matter where the data is on spark on
dusk or appendix
and after the logical partition
each data frame or each side each small
partition will contain only one color
and then with this data frame we can
perform the validation
so this will significantly simplify the
task for validation framework
because
field level takes care of the
partitioning and then the validation
work the validation framework they only
need to
focus on with the same logical partition
always the same color of data frame how
can i perform the validation so as you
can see no surprise the code will become
much much simpler than before
so here we just define uh hypothesis
testing as before but we no longer need
to have the group by and samples those
two tricky parameters
straightforward and also in this data
frame schema
we only set one check instead of many
checks
because this will operate on just one
partition of data that contains only one
color
with this idea
you can take a look how long it takes to
operate on exactly the same data set
8.2 seconds
compared to this it's almost two times
faster
and it is also simpler and more
intuitive
okay so now let's bring this to dusk how
can i run this partition uh partitioning
uh partition and validate logic on desk
so actually it's very straightforward we
just change this data frame to a dash
data frame where we directly load from
file
and then we just specified the backhand
to be dusk
and as you can see even on the same
kegel notebook cargo machine
and even this process is reading from
file it is still faster
than the pendants version so this is the
power of a distributed computing system
if you have a very powerful computing
cluster it can process huge amount of
data
within very reasonable time
okay the next scenario is actually an
addition
to the existing scenario to the previous
scenario so besides validating the
distributions by color we also want to
validate
the ranges for each color so remember
that we have this variable we have this
dictionary specifying the range for
different color how can we apply this
dictionary
to the entire data set
so again here is
the native pandera solution
as you can see this is normal check is
the previous code but this is new
this is to validate the range by
different colors
and what we have to do is we have to
treat
the input data frame as a key value pair
so a as a dictionary so in the
dictionary the key will be the colors
and the value will be the sub data
frames belonging to that color and we
have to go through every key value pair
of that groups and for each group we
have to make sure the mean and max
are within the given range
right and not only this
we also have to um we also have to add
this additional check
to the um collection of normal checks
so we get one more check in the
checklist
and the other things will stay the same
and also by the way if you have group by
no matter here or here you have to have
a dummy color validation inside the
pandara dataframe schema
right
so now let's take a look how long it
takes on the entire data set
it was 15 some seconds and now
it's 16.6 seconds
now let's take a look if we fugue how we
solve this problem
just like before
with fugue it takes care of the
partitioning so the pandera level check
will only face one color different so
the problem becomes much simpler here
the only thing we added is just one line
of code and this is a cross column
validation
where this data frame
is already partitioned by color and so
we just need to make sure that the
weight is between the ranges that is
determined by the color column value of
the sub data frame
again it is simpler and also it is much
faster than the previous solution
now let's write a distributedly using
mask and see how long it takes
so again if you want run everything on
spark just change this to a spark
session you initialize it by yourself
and this data frame can be appended data
frame or it can be a spark data frame
and as you can see
using dusk it is still faster than the
pendant solution even on the same
machine
in the last scenario
i just want to talk about something
different
so in scenario three we still have the
ranges to use right and in the last
scenario we no longer have this
dictionary we want to profile the sample
data set
and figure out
this dictionary
and in this section
i'm going to show how few can integrate
greeks with great expectations
and first of all let's take a look at
the great expectations code
one thing i really like about gray
expectation is they have a feature
called mostly
let's take a look at the example so if
you want to apply the range validation
on a certain column first of all you
convert this data frame
into a grid expectation
data frame
and then you can just directly apply
your validation i want to as a assert
that the weight column is between 70 and
500. this is a bad number because
i know there are weights that's under
17. so this should fail
this should give me a false
but
with this mostly
of 0.8
i think this will succeed because i know
that most of the data in sample
they are greater than 70.
so mostly
make it not 100
but almost
so as you can see this is false and this
is true
this mostly is very very useful if you
want to fully automate
your profiling and validation pipeline
because
you profile on the existing data
and for the new unseen data
it is very common to see outliers
although it's very small percentage
it makes the validation come 60 con
can't be 100 so you must set them mostly
to a number
that is close to one but not one
okay with this in mind let's see how we
can write
a simple validation function that can
perform the validation
on uh if the data frame is already
partitioned into a single color
okay so this is the function
we take several parameters the first
parameter is the min max
belonging to that color
and the second is a sub pandas data
frame belong to that color and third is
the mostly parameter
and what we do is we just convert
this data frame
to the
grid expectation data frame
and then we perform the validation
and here we just get the mean and the
max from the first parameter
and also we provide the mostly and only
if this result is not successful
we return the color value
and the failed result as string
so look at this function
it is just a python function nothing
special has nothing to do with view has
nothing to do with sparkle dusk
so we can just do some unit tests on it
let's use the red color as an example
assume that the mean is 70 and max is
200
again we know that
70 most of the data will be more than 70
but there are some that is under 70. so
if mostly is 0.8
then the process will succeed
it will yield nothing
we should get an empty array here but if
mostly is one
then we should get something we should
get the red color plus a result let's
see if this is the case so this is the
case so if you provide mostly
and then it is empty otherwise contain
something
okay with this simple validate function
now we want to see how we can leverage
field
to do the auto profiling
plus distributed validation
so look at this function
this is also an advanced use case for
fugue so you need to initialize the
field workflow so fuga is all about
directed acyclic graph
and here just use that
big workflow directly
and the first step
we just need to bring
the data frame into the workflow
and then we want to select color and min
and max of weight
so actually this is a group by color and
to get min and max of weight
this constructs
the ranges that we've we found in the
previous sections
but it's in the data frame
in the data frame format so it's fully
scalable
no matter how many partitions how many
colors you have
and on the second step we will just zip
the ranges and this data together
because they have the common column
called color so
they will zip together by the color and
if you zip together and say transform by
validate so it will zip partition by
color and for each partition we will
apply this function so this min max and
this subset they will belong to each
color
and also here is how we provide the
mostly parameter and in the end we
should get a list of error reports right
how can we deal with that error reports
in the summarize function if the error
reports is is a list of um errors then
we should us we should assert that there
is no error
but if there is any error we will just
throw in a certain uh exception
where the message will be the first
three error reports
so for this part
it will run with the given engine
that you specified
and if there is no problem this will
finish silently otherwise it will throw
an exception
if this finishes silently then we can
just return the original data set
so this is the solution
that
can help you to do scalable distributed
profiling and validation by different
partitions
as you can see if we test
if we profile our sample and then apply
back on sample
we can set the mostly to 1.0 there is no
issue at all
but if we set
[Music]
the uh
the data
and then we still expect it to finish
100 percent
in row 5th
and if we relax the mostly to 0.8
it will pass
and in the end we just
bring this
to a distributed environment by
providing
a task data frame here
and ending the back end here
so actually as you can see in this
function
we mixed the data frames so in for fugue
we can take any type of data frames and
we can also mix them so for example this
can be a smart keyframe this can be a
dust net frame
and where to run really depends on the
engine
so now this function is fully scalable
and it can operate on a very big data
set
okay to wrap up
greek expectations
is feature rich and pandera is
straightforward they both have very good
support for pandas dataframes but both
of them lack intuitive and scalable
interface to do per group validations
and if you can um help on in this
scenario because
it can help it can make great
expectations and pandera to focus
on the single logical partition and the
pandas-based validations
and if you can take care of the rest for
example various data sources various
computing engines
partitioning
and the computing
orchestration
in general if you can make
the validations
much simpler and much faster
but of course
it has to integrate with great
expectations and the panderas
to achieve this
so fugue is open source you can just
pipping store fugue sql
and you can also visit
our website
and the kaggle notebook i talked about
today
is is here it's public
and if you want to chat with
our team
just go to select.ai
thank you